good morning everybody sorry for getting
you all up so early at 10:00 we started
oculus years ago to enable new
experiences it would transform gaming
and entertainment through the power of
virtual reality we've talked a lot today
about how we're doing that with the rift
but we're not done yet we've been
working on Virtual Reality input since
the very earliest days in of oculus
always looking at ways to open new
experiences that are only possible with
cutting-edge future technology now we
see virtual reality input evolving over
the coming years and there will be
different inputs for different types of
games especially as developers optimize
content for different kinds of games
River developers have been working with
gamepads for years in VR they've proven
that you can make really compelling
content with a gamepad and you know a
lot of these partners we've been working
with we've been working for one or even
two years on these projects and it's
really fantastic to be here showing them
off but we see virtual reality come
input coming in lots of different forms
depending on what kind of experience
you're looking for Brendan talked about
how excited we are to include the Xbox
one controller as part of the rift to
make sure that developers have something
that they can target that they know
every single person who has the rift
will have something that they can design
their game to work very effectively with
and the Xbox controller is a key part of
the current virtual reality puzzle for
example it's currently the absolute best
way to play games like Lucky's tale edge
of nowhere or eval Curie
it just is but what about future games
of future experiences that can only be
unlocked with a different input device
I've seen thousands of people inside the
rift now I've been thousands of demos
and one of the first things that a lot
of people do is they reach out into this
virtual world it's something entirely
new to them and it's a natural reaction
to something that they've never
experienced before we wanted to create
an input device that actually lets
people reach out that lets those people
interact with objects in the virtual
world let me show you what we've been
working on
this is oculus touch these are going to
take virtual reality gaming to the next
level
come on let's clap let's do it
[Applause]
oculus touch is a pair of track
controllers that we've created to take
VR to the next level
these are feature prototypes for oculus
touch a set of prototypes that were code
that we've codenamed Half Moon we wanted
to enable the best and absolute widest
range of virtual reality experiences and
to do that we had a number of goals for
the half moon project first we wanted to
deliver hand presence the sense of
feeling as though your virtual hands are
actually your real hands this is
critical to nailing the sense of overall
presence once you have your hands
involved you really need tracking to be
absolutely perfect accurate and low
latency are you're gonna feel like your
hands are dead precise manipulation of
virtual entities in the virtual space is
also absolutely critical for example you
need to be able to pick up a gun from a
table and then fire it throw it or drop
it effortlessly without even having to
think about it this required a lot of
design on how to make the controller
interactions as natural as possible
overall we wanted a design that was low
mental load that you something you
wouldn't have to think about something
that would let you use these controllers
effortlessly like you use your real
hands in the real world we also wanted
to enable communicative gestures for
social interactions imagine pointing
waving or giving a thumbs up these are
the types of experiences that half-moon
enables and another priority was
including proven traditional inputs like
buttons and analog sticks we want to
enable a lot of different kinds of
virtual reality experiences entirely new
VR only experiences genres of games that
have been around for decades that are
being bought into via into VR and also
hybrid experiences that incorporate the
best of traditional input with the best
of virtual reality input buttons and
analog sticks are still around for a
reason they've been proven to be a great
way to interact with calm
likes games there's something everyone
knows how to use there's something that
developers have proven is critical for a
lot of different types of genre like
simulation or platforming those types of
inputs are not going anywhere
finally oculus touch needs to be
lightweight and ergonomic and it to be
easy to get in and out of and it had to
be comfortable for extremely long
periods of play whether you're standing
and reaching out into the virtual world
or whether you're sitting on your couch
with your controllers resting in your
lap see that rest sit on my lap so we've
built the happen prototypes with several
key features there's two controllers one
for each hand you have two hands they're
mirror images of each other like the two
hands that you have they're wireless so
you can move and interact in the virtual
world freely unencumbered by cables they
have integrated high precision low
latency six degree of freedom track six
degree of freedom tracking leveraging
the same constellation trash tracking
technology that we use in the wrist
along with integrated inertial
measurement units now each of these
half-moon controllers has a traditional
analog thumb stick two buttons and a non
analog trigger but they also have
something else that we call the hand
trigger you can see the trigger right
there under my middle finger imagine
using this to pick up a virtual gun and
then using your index finger to fire it
touch also includes haptics the
developers can use to deliver feedback
when you're interacting with objects in
the virtual world so that you can
actually feel the things that you're
touching finally though touch can detect
a set of finger-posts using a matrix of
center sensors mounted throughout the
inside of the device together they work
to recognize natural hand poses like
pointing waving or giving a thumbs up we
built a new demo for oculus touch
showing this off that we call toy box
and we'll be showing it off for the
first time to the public at e3 Twitter's
actually our internal prototyping
testbed that we've used to design the
half Moone prototypes and to experiment
with new features and interactions it's
really a great sandbox for playing with
things you
and light explosives dual wield laser
guns pull robots limb from limb
punch garden gnomes play tetherball just
a lot of really fun interactions that
we've been experimenting with on our way
to natural virtual reality and foot and
one of the coolest things about toybox
is that it's a social experience it's a
multiplayer experience you're actually
in a space with another person using the
controllers far away but you feel like
you're in the same place and what's
amazing about that is that as the
experience gets more natural you start
to actually feel like you're in the same
place with this person you start to wave
to them or to gesture to things so that
they can pick them up and you do it
without even thinking about it because
you kind of feel like the person is
really there in the room with you even
though they're actually down the hall in
one of the other test spots we really
think that oculus touch is going to
surprise you and I'm really excited to
show off Toby box to a lot of people
I'll be actually running a lot of the
demos at e3 so we might get a chance to
play together
so that's oculus touch we think they're
going to deliver an entirely new set of
virtual reality experiences and we can't
wait to see what developers have in
store the last few years have been
incredible for virtual reality things
have come so far so fast if you were to
show someone a video of this event today
or heck even all the technology that's
in the virtual reality industry across
all these different companies not just
oculus you took a video of that and
showed it to someone three or four years
ago they would have thought that it
looked like a science fiction film it
would have been a perfect cue but this
isn't science fiction this is reality
and it's happening today thank you I'll
see all of you at e3
[Applause]
you